Being a stay at home mom is a job.
Being a stay at home wife is a job.
Taking care of the house
while your husband provides for you is a job.
So when a woman stays at home
while her husband provides for her and isn't working,
she is working
and her husband is covering the cost of that work.
When you pay a nanny to take care of your kids,
when you drop your kids off at daycare
and pay the daycare,
when you pay a housekeeper,
a house manager,
to take care of the house,
that's considered work.
All of the work that those people are doing
is considered work.
But when a woman who stays at home does it,
it's not work.
No, very much is work,
and it's hard work.